right
[Music]
George Floyd's six-year-old daughter
Gianna already knows the impact her dad
has had on the world and now she has an
official Instagram account with her mom
Roxie Washington to thank all of the
people that have been rallying around
her including some of Hollywood's
biggest stars Gigi's dad George Floyd a
46 year old black man in Minneapolis
died when a police officer pressed his
knee into his neck for more than eight
minutes sparking protests against police
brutality and racial injustice worldwide
since then stars like Kanye West have
come forward offering up their support
to George's little girl the rapper set
up a college fund that will cover her
full tuition Gigi shared this pic on
Instagram that reads Thank You Kanye
because of you I will have a college
education and she gave a shout out to
Kanye's wife Kim Kardashian in the
caption mommy and I are so thankful for
you and your family Barbra Streisand
also stepped up gifting Gianna with
shares of Disney stock Gigi shared
several snaps to her Instagram Sunday
showing off the special package from the
music icon alongside the caption I am
now a Disney stockholder thanks to you
then on Thursday Gianna shared a clip
from John Legend's Father's Day special
hey everybody it's John Legend some
friends and I are celebrating fathers
day and she thanked him for the special
tribute to her dad in the caption Gigi's
insta account also features pictures of
letters cards art and more sent to her
from people all around the world
she and her momma wrote that they are so
grateful for the love and support I
don't have but I like to say because I
can't get my words together right now
earlier this month
Roxie spoke out making a tearful
statement with her daughter by her side
at Minneapolis City Hall you know it
does not have a
he will never see grow up graduate he
will never walk down if it's a problem
she's having it she needs a day she does
not have that anymore the
mother-daughter pair also sat down with
CNN that day where Roxy opened up about
having to tell her daughter about
George's death my wife said because I
get him saying my name on TV she wanted
to know how he died hey the only thing
that I can tell is Bri
[Music]